Juli 2008.
Ein Spezialflug aus Libyen
landet in Genf.
An Bord: Hannibal Gaddafi,
Sohn des mächtigen Diktators,
seine Gattin,
Leibwächter und Dienstpersonal.
Hannibal gilt als pervers,
brutal und eitel.
Er frönt dem Alkohol und führt
einen ausschweifenden Lebensstil.
Seine Gattin Aline ist Model
und stammt aus dem Libanon.
Die beiden kommen nach Genf,
weil Aline hier ihr 2. Kind
auf die Welt bringen möchte.
Die Schweiz war für sie
beispielhaft, das perfekte Land.
Das Paar und sein
Gefolge logieren im Hotel President,
einem der teuersten der Welt.
Sie belegen 10 Zimmer
und eine Suite im 3. Stock.
Doch in diesen luxuriösen Räumen
spielen sich unschöne Szenen ab.
Die Ehe von Hannibal
und seiner schönen Frau
ist alles andere
als harmonisch.
Die Zimmermädchen
sehen und hören alles.
Hannibal trinkt zu viel
und erzürnt damit seine Gattin.
Diese lässt ihre Wut
an ihrem Dienstmädchen Ahlem aus.
Jeden Tag misshandelt sie die
junge Frau, bringt sie zum Weinen.
Dann, eines Tages, hält Ahlem
die Misshandlungen nicht mehr aus.
Die Überwachsungskameras,
hier erstmals zu sehen,
sind Zeugen des Dramas.
Hier zeigen sie
Alines Hausmädchen Ahlem und Kamal,
Hannibals Mann für alles.
Ihr Schicksal schweisst sie zusammen.
Samstag, 7. Juli 2008.
Ahlem verlässt verängstigt
die Suite von Aline.
Laut ihrer Aussage hat ihre Herrin
sie mit einem hölzernen Kleiderbügel
geschlagen.
Am nächsten Tag
wird Ahlem erneut geschlagen
und bittet
das Zimmermädchen um Hilfe.
Sie sagt, Aline wolle sie nach
ihrer Rückkehr in Libyen töten.
Das Hotelpersonal
alarmiert die Polizei.
Am 12. Juli 2008
sprechen Polizeibeamte im Hotel vor.
Als sie die Verletzungen
von Ahlem und Kamal sehen,
nehmen sie die beiden mit.
Es ist 17.55 Uhr.
Ahlem und Kamal
wagen das Unglaubliche.
Sie zeigen das Paar an,
das sich für unantastbar hält.
Was noch keiner ahnt:
Die beiden verwöhnten Schützlinge
von Diktator Gaddafi
lösen eine
der grössten Krisen aus,
welche die Schweiz je erlebt hat.
Das Verfahren
nimmt seinen Lauf.
Falls die beiden
diplomatische Immunität geniessen,
wird die Polizei wegschauen.
Andernfalls werden sie
zur Rechenschaft gezogen.
Ich repräsentierte Genf
am 14. Juli im Elysee-Palast.
Mein Generalsekretär
rief mich an und sagte mir,
es liege eine Anklage
und einen Verhaftungsbeschluss
gegen die beiden vor.
Ich fragte, ob ihre Immunität
geprüft worden sei,
und er sagte,
Bern habe grünes Licht gegeben.
In seiner Mitteilung
bestätigt das Aussendepartement,
dass Hannibal Gaddafi
keinen Diplomatenstatus geniesse.
Doch Bern ist sich
der politischen Risiken bewusst
und bittet Genf, diskret vorzugehen.
Wir haben beim Bund
die Verhaftung beantragt
und dieser
hat uns grünes Licht gegeben.
Warum hätten wir in diesem
Fall eine Ausnahme machen sollen?
Uns hat man gefragt, ob er wohl
Immunität geniesse oder nicht.
Wir sagten, dass er keine habe.
Wenn man eine solche Person
warnen würde,
ist das in der Schweiz strafbar,
denn man trägt dazu bei,
dass die Person
nicht strafverfolgt werden kann.
Wenn man bedenkt,
was Hannibal Gaddafi gemacht hat,
Man muss sagen, dass wir
ein Interesse daran hatten,
dass es auch
zu einer Strafverfolgung kommt.
Ein Anruf ins Hotel hätte genügt
und sie wären diskret entwischt.
In Paris oder London wurde
ihnen diese Sonderbehandlung gewährt.
Doch hierzulande
ist das Gesetz für alle gleich.
In diesem Punkt
sind sich Genf und Bern einig.
Die Genfer Polizei weiss von
Hannibals unrühmlicher Vergangenheit:
In Rom
war er in eine Schlägerei verwickelt.
In Paris raste er mit 140 km/h
auf der falschen Strassenseite
über die Champs Elysee.
Ausserdem hatte er
seine schwangere Frau geschlagen,
und in Paris
mit einer Pistole herumgefuchtelt.
Ohne zu zögern, beschliesst
die Genfer Polizei, ihn zu verhaften.
Die Überwachungskameras filmen,
wie der Sohn des libyschen Diktators
am 15. Juli 2008 festgenommen wird.
1 1/2 Std. lang
versucht die Polizei
mit der libyschen Delegation
zu verhandeln.
Sie soll Hannibal überzeugen,
freiwillig
auf den Polizeiposten zu kommen.
12.20 Uhr. Die Verhandlungen
kommen nicht voran.
Da gibt der Einsatzleiter
grünes Licht.
20 Polizeibeamte stürmen
in den 3. Stock des Hotels.
Doch Hannibals Leibwächter versperren
den Zugang zu seiner Suite.
Die Polizei überwältigt sie.
Dabei
wird ein Polizeibeamter gebissen
und ein Leibwächter
am Kopf verletzt.
12.25 Uhr.
Ein Sicherheitsbeamter des Hotels
öffnet die 3 Türen
von Hannibals Suite.
Die Beamten überwältigen ihn.
Er leistet keinen Widerstand.
Die Polizei dringt darauf
ins Zimmer von Aline ein
und nimmt sie vor den Augen
ihres 3-jährigen Sohns fest.
12.35 Uhr.
Hannibal wird abgeführt.
Die Operation hat 10 Min. gedauert.
Um kein Aufsehen zu erregen,
führt die Polizei Hannibal
durch eine Hintertür ab
und setzt ihn in einen Mercedes
mit verdunkelten Fensterscheiben.
Die Genfer Polizei
hat Gaddafi Junior festgenommen,
aber er wird
wie jeder Normalsterbliche
in die nächste Polizeiwache
gebracht.
Dort darf er rauchen.
Ein Beamter bietet ihm ein Bier an.
Doch er lehnt ab,
da es alkoholfrei ist.
Nervös behauptet Hannibal,
die Hausangestellten
hätten sich selbst verletzt.
Er verbringt die Nacht
in der Zelle.
Aline, die im 8. Monat schwanger ist,
wird mit der Ambulanz
ins Krankenhaus gefahren,
wo sie unter ärztlicher und polizei-
licher Kontrolle die Nacht verbringt.
Für die Genfer Polizei läuft alles
korrekt, sie handelt nach Gesetz.
Noch weiss sie nicht,
wozu ihr Häftling fähig ist.
Dann lanciert Hannibal
seinen ersten Angriff.
Er behauptet, die Polizei habe ihm
einen Plastiksack
über den Kopf gestülpt.
Ich weise seine Beschuldigung
vollumfänglich zurück.
Die Genfer Polizei
benützt nie Plastiksäcke,
wenn sie jemanden verhaftet,
und sicher nicht, wenn es sich
um Gaddafi Junior handelt.
2 Tage nach der Verhaftung, nachdem
der Hoteldirektor bestätigt hatte,
dass im Zimmer
nichts beschädigt worden sei,
verwüsteten Hannibals Leute
die Suite.
Sie wollten den Eindruck erwecken,
seine Verhaftung sei auf
nicht tolerierbare Weise erfolgt.
Eine der vielen Inszenierungen
in dieser Affäre.
Die Narbe von Hannibals Haus-
angestellten Kamal ist hingegen real.
Hannibal hat mich
in sein privates Gefängnis gebracht,
wo ich täglich geschlagen wurde.
Mein ganzer Körper
weist Spuren davon auf.
Er hat mich
mit einem Messer verletzt.
Da sind Abdrücke
der Handschellen.
Viele Spuren zeigen, dass er uns
wie Sklaven behandelt hat.
Aline hat mich schwer misshandelt.
Sie hat mich geschlagen,
an den Haaren gerissen,
mit heissem Wasser verbrüht,
in die Brüste gekniffen,
mit einem Kleiderbügel geschlagen.
Sie schlug mich jeden Tag.
Ich war ihre Gefangene.
Mein einziger Ausweg war,
die Polizei zu alarmieren.
Hannibals Gattin
wird im Krankenhaus vernommen.
Sie streitet alles ab: die Drohungen,
die Schläge, die Verletzungen.
Auf die Frage,
ob sie Drogen nehme, sagt sie:
"Nein, ich bin schwanger."
Am 17. Juli 2008,
2 Tage nach der Verhaftung,
stehen sich
Beschuldigte und Kläger gegenüber.
In diesem Raum wird das Paar
Gaddafi dem Richter vorgeführt.
Und hinter verspiegelten Scheiben
sind ihre beiden
terrorisierten Angestellten.
Auch während der Verhandlung
wurden sie beleidigt.
Sie haben mir erzählt,
dass Hannibal sie als Schweinehunde
und Hurensöhne bezeichnet habe.
der Richter habe das nicht bemerkt,
weil es nicht übersetzt wurde.
Aline verneinte alles
und verstand die Welt nicht mehr.
Hannibal war aggressiv,
herablassend und verachtend.
Sie sahen sich als Könige,
die über das Leben
ihrer Angestellten verfügen konnten.
Das Paar kommt gegen Kaution frei:
500'000 Fr., ein Geschenk
für die Multimilliardäre.
Ihre Anwälte beteuern,
dass keinerlei Fluchtgefahr bestehe.
Unser Klient
wird auf keinen Fall fliehen.
Er hat keinen Anlass,
die Schweiz zu verlassen.
Er will der Justiz helfen.
Einige Stunden später
fliegt Hannibal mit seiner Familie
und seinem Gefolge nach Tripolis.
Und Ayesha al-Gaddafi, die mächtige
Tochter des libyschen Herrschers,
tritt mit einer Warnung auf:
Auge um Auge, Zahn um Zahn.
Unrecht hat derjenige,
der begonnen hat.
Tripolis, 15. Juli 2008.
Ein wolkenloser Sommermorgen.
Noch scheinen die Beziehungen
zwischen der Schweiz und Libyen
ungetrübt.
Da stört
ein hoher libyscher Beamter
die Idylle
in der Schweizer Botschaft
durch
eine ungeheuerliche Nachricht:
Hannibal wurde in Genf verhaftet.
Er sagte mir sehr offen:
"Wir wissen, dass sich Hannibal
nicht immer korrekt verhält."
"Doch das ist für uns zweitrangig."
"Am wichtigsten ist für uns,
und dafür müssen Sie sorgen:
Die Medien
dürfen nicht darüber berichten."
Da sagte ich:
"Ich kenne keine Details,
aber was ich sicher
nicht verhindern kann, ist,
dass die Medien
davon Wind bekommen."
Die libysche Diktatur
kennt keine Pressefreiheit.
Entsprechend eisig reagiert
der libysche Gesprächspartner.
Alarmiert greift
Botschafter von Muralt zum Telefon.
In Genf sagt man ihm nichts -
Untersuchungsgeheimnis.
In Bern sind alle in den Ferien.
Ein Funktionär versucht
den Diplomaten zu beruhigen und sagt:
"Ich bete für Sie."
Das war wie Hiroshima.
Wir wussten, wir würden gigantische
Probleme bekommen, das war klar.
In Crans sur Celigny,
wo Rachid Hamdani
mit seiner Tessiner Gemahlin lebt,
bereitet sich der Geschäftsmann
auf seine Reise nach Tripolis vor.
Ich hörte
im Radio die Geschichte mit Hannibal
und dass er verhaftet worden war.
Meine Frau fragte mich: "Willst du
wirklich nach Libyen fliegen?"
Ich sagte: "Warum denn nicht",
und bestieg das Flugzeug."
Als Rachid Hamdani
libyschen Boden betritt,
wird er
bereits von Gaddafis Leuten gesucht.
Sie sind in sein Büro eingedrungen.
Gegen 11 Uhr rief mich
meine Sekretärin an und sagte:
"Die Polizei kam, versiegelte das
Büro, stellte Wasser und Strom ab
und sagte zu uns, dass wir hier
nicht mehr arbeiten dürften."
"Das sei ein illegales Büro."
Aber Rachid Hamdani hat keine Angst.
Er glaubt sich geschützt
durch seine schweizerisch-
tunesische Doppelbürgerschaft.
Sei Partner ist Miguel Stucky.
Ihre Geschäfte laufen gut.
Die beiden hatten schon Aufträge
vom libyschen Regime,
und ein Vertrauter von Gaddafi ist
sogar Aktionär ihrer Gesellschaft.
Doch nun gilt Rachid Hamdani
als Persona non grata.
Die libysche Polizei
ist hinter ihm her.
Am Abend kreuzen 3 bewaffnete Männer
bei ihm auf.
Ohne ihm zu erklären warum, nehmen
sie ihn auf den Polizeiposten mit.
Dort sassen 4 Männer auf dem Boden,
tranken Tee und riefen:
"Endlich haben wir
einen Schweizer Direktor!"
Ich verstand nicht,
was mit mir passierte.
Zur gleichen Zeit knöpft sich die
Polizei einen anderen Schweizer vor.
Dieser hat einen typisch
schweizerischen Namen: Max Göldi.
Er ist Länderchef der ABB in Libyen.
Max Göldi bleibt ruhig.
Er hat ein reines Gewissen.
Er rief die Botschaft an und sagte:
"Die Polizei ist bei mir,
was soll ich tun?"
Dort hiess es:
Das sind Staatsvertreter.
Sie dürfen
keinen Widerstand leisten.
Max Göldi duscht,
zieht eine Krawatte an
und folgt den Polizeibeamten.
Brutal und ohne Erklärungen
werden Rachid Hamdani und Max Göldi
in eines der finstersten Gefängnissen
von Gaddafi gebracht.
Der Tod wäre mir lieber gewesen
als diese Situation.
Jede Minute empfand ich als Qual.
Die Zelle war schrecklich,
wie ein Tierkäfig.
Es gab keine Fenster,
nur eine Öffnung in der Decke,
durch die Luft hereinkam.
In der Zelle waren wir 18 Männer
und es gab nur 12 Betten.
Es waren die schlimmsten Momente
meines Lebens.
Gaddafis Leute haben es
auch auf einen 3. Mann abgesehen,
einen deutschschweizerischen
Handwerker,
der in diesem Moment
nach Europa zurückfliegen will.
Während Wochen wird er
zu einem streng gehüteten Geheimnis:
Die 3. Schweizer Geisel.
Er wurde verfolgt
und fühlte sich bedroht.
Doch es gelang ihm,
ein Taxi zu nehmen
und in die Botschaft zu flüchten.
Er blieb bei uns,
bis es uns gelang,
ihm ein Visum
zu beschaffen und ihn auszufliegen.
Inzwischen ist klar: Kein Schweizer
ist in Libyen mehr sicher.
Ganze Familien
suchen Schutz in der Botschaft.
Alle glaubten, die Libyer
seien hinter jedem Schweizer her.
Gaddafis Anhänger
schrien vor der Botschaft:
"Nieder mit der Schweiz. Der Sohn
unseres Führers wurde gedemütigt!"
Und ich fragte mich:
Was mache ich nun?
Der Botschafter wird unter Druck
gesetzt und Tag und Nacht bedrängt.
Eines Nachts
wird er gegen Mitternacht vorgeladen.
Man legt ihm
ein Beweisstück vor, das zeigen soll,
wie schlecht Hannibal
in Genf behandelt worden sei.
Ein Mann kommt auf mich zu,
zeigt mir ein weisses T-Shirt
mit Blutflecken und sagt:
"Stellen Sie sich vor,
Herr Botschafter,
das ist Hannibals T-Shirt." So wurde
er im Genfer Gefängnis behandelt."
Ich gestehe Ihnen. Ich musste leer
schlucken. Dann sagte ich:
"In unseren Gefängnissen
behandelt man die Leute nicht so."
Nach 10 Tagen werden Max Göldi
und Rachid Hamdani
aus dem Gefängnis entlassen.
Aber sie müssen in Libyen bleiben.
Ihre Geschäfte bleiben geschlossen,
ihre Pässe konfisziert.
Bern schickt eine Delegation
nach Tripolis.
Noch glaubt die Schweiz,
es gehe um Verhandlungen
zwischen 2 zivilisierten Staaten.
Wir meinten, wir könnten die Krise
mit einer Erklärung des Bedauerns
lösen.
Libyen lässt sich nicht erweichen.
Da beschliesst die Schweiz,
die Geiseln zu befreien.
Aussenministerin Micheline Calmy-Rey
beauftragt Spezialkräfte,
einen entsprechenden Plan
auszuarbeiten.
Da die Verhandlungen harzten,
wollten wir die Libyer überlisten.
Hätten wir das nicht versucht,
würde man es uns vorwerfen.
Der Schweizer Geheimdienst teilt
seine Pläne dem Botschafter mit,
der die Geiseln informiert.
Ich informierte die beiden
auf dem Dach der Botschaft,
damit uns niemand hören konnte,
weil wir ja nicht wussten,
ob die Botschaft verwanzt war.
Der Plan ist einfach:
Die beiden sollen das Schwimmbad
des Telekomriesen Ericsson besuchen.
Laut Plan sollten die beiden
ins Ericsson-Gebäude gehen.
Dort würde ein Auto mit einem
libyschen Fahrer auf sie warten
und sie über Ghadames
nach Algerien fahren.
Doch im letzten Moment,
ich weiss nicht weshalb,
wurde es abgeblasen.
Ein anderer Plan
wird geschmiedet.
Die beiden werden angewiesen,
Jetskis zu mieten
und aufs Meer hinaus zu fahren,
wo sie von Schweizer Spezialeinheiten
evakuiert werden sollen.
Doch auch dieses Vorhaben
scheitert im letzten Moment.
Daniel von Muralt hat
Meinungsverschiedenheiten mit Bern
und wird
in die Schweiz zurückgerufen.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt
sitzen Max und Rachid
bereits ein Jahr in Libyen fest.
Die Sache wurde von Anfang an
schlecht angegangen.
Leider verstanden
die Schweizer Behörden nicht,
wie Gaddafi
und dessen Familie tickten.
Hannibal, sein Halbbruder Mutassim,
seine Schwester und sein Vater
waren schlecht
auf die Schweiz zu sprechen.
Seif al-Islam war flexibler, aber
seine Meinung zählte leider nicht.
Hannibal sagte mir etwas,
das mich sehr beunruhigte:
Wenn Sie diese Geschichte so regeln,
dass Sie
die beiden Schweizer ausfliegen,
jage ich das Flugzeug in die Luft."
Hannibal will nur eines:
sich rächen. Und er weiss,
sein Vater steht hinter ihm.
Hans Rudolf Merz ist überzeugt,
vermitteln zu können,
als er im August 2009
in Tripolis landet.
Der Schweizer Bundespräsident ist
bereit, mit Ministern zu verhandeln,
obwohl in Libyen allein
Muammar-al Gaddafi entscheidet.
Merz macht Konzessionen:
Die Schweiz werde sich entschuldigen
und das Verhalten
der Genfer Polizei untersuchen.
Sogar die Namen der Polizisten,
die Hannibal verhaftet haben,
plant Merz offenbar preiszugeben.
Zuversichtlich
reist Merz nach Bern zurück.
Meine Damen und Herren,
Ich orientiere Sie
über eine Reise nach Libyen,
die ich gestern nach mehrmonatiger
Vorbereitung vornehmen konnte.
Die Schweiz hat einen neuen
Geschäftsträger für Libyen ernannt:
Stefano Lazzarotto.
Die Geiseln
haben ihre Pässe zurückbekommen.
Die Freilassung scheint nur noch
eine Frage der Zeit.
Doch dann publiziert eine Zeitung
die Polizeibilder von Hannibal.
Der künftige Bundesrat
Didier Burkhalter erklärt öffentlich,
Schweizer Spezialkräfte
sollten die Geiseln zurückholen.
Und noch schlimmer
aus libyscher Sicht:
Micheline Calmy-Rey verweigert
dem populärsten der Gaddafi-Söhne
die Einreise.
Seif al-Islam verlangte ein Visum.
Wir beschlossen,
es ihm zu verweigern,
da wir sein Gesuch unter den
Umständen als Provokation empfanden.
Es war eine sehr schwierige Zeit,
denn die Geiseln waren in Gefahr.
Jeder Schritt, den wir unternahmen,
konnte sich gegen sie richten.
Die libyschen Behörden
lassen sich nichts anmerken
und bitten die Schweizer
zur angeblich letzten
medizinischen Kontrolle
vor der Ausreise ins Krankenhaus.
Alles schien normal.
V.a. hatte man uns versprochen,
wir könnten in 3 Tagen ausreisen.
Was sie uns sagten,
schien zu stimmen.
Ein Arzt empfängt sie.
Er bittet den Schweizer Diplomaten,
am Eingang zu warten
und nimmt Max und Rachid mit.
Sie führten uns in ein Zimmer, wo
man uns den Blutdruck messen wollte.
Meiner war sehr hoch: 220.
Der Arzt ordnet ein Elektrokardio-
gramm und eine Röntgenaufnahme an.
Die Geiseln werden von einem Raum
in den andern geführt.
Plötzlich stösst man sie
durch eine Geheimtür.
Max versuchte noch Lazzarotto
anzurufen, um ihn zu informieren.
Aber man liess ihn
nicht telefonieren.
Dann stiessen sie uns in ein Auto,
das davonbrauste.
Vor der Notaufnahme wird der
Schweizer Diplomat immer nervöser.
Er kann die beiden Geiseln
nicht mehr erreichen.
Die beiden Männer, die er beschützen
sollte, wurden gekidnappt.
Ich wurde wütend, als ich merkte,
was passiert war.
Dann musste ich ihren Familien
erklären,
dass die beiden verschwunden seien,
und wir nicht wussten, wo sie waren.
Der Diplomat sucht Max und Rachid
in ganz Tripolis
und in allen Gefängnissen.
Geplagt von Schuldgefühlen und
der Angst um die beiden Geiseln,
verliert er in wenigen Wochen 10 kg.
Während der ganzen Zeit ihrer
Gefangenschaft wussten wir nicht,
ob sie noch am Leben waren.
Ich denke,
das gehörte zur Strategie Libyens.
Man wollte uns
damit unter Druck setzen.
Max und Rachid werden an
einem geheimen Ort gefangen gehalten,
7 Wochen lang isoliert
und von der Welt abgeschnitten.
Sie hätten uns töten
oder irgendwohin schicken können,
wo uns niemand mehr gefunden hätte.
Unsere Regierung
konnte nichts mehr tun,
um uns
aus dieser Situation zu befreien.
Die Zellen der beiden
Schweizer sind nebeneinander.
Aber sie haben keinen Kontakt
und können nur mutmassen,
ob der andere noch lebt,
anhand von Spuren in der Dusche
oder Schuhen vor der Türe.
Dieses Gefühl der Isolierung
spüre ich heute noch.
Es war für mich, als gäbe es mich
nicht mehr, als sei ich tot.
Der libysche Vizeaussenminister
erklärt im Schweizer Fernsehen,
die beiden seien
weder entführt worden,
noch würden sie
als Geiseln festgehalten.
Wir haben sie
in Sicherheit gebracht,
wegen der Publikationen
in Ihren Medien,
gewissen Äusserungen eines Parlamen-
tariers und aus anderen Gründen.
Die beiden Schweizer
sind keine Geiseln.
Die einzige Chance,
das Kräfteverhältnis zu ändern
und das Leben der Geiseln
zu retten und sie zu befreien, war,
die EU einzubeziehen,
die Krise zu europäisieren.
Das Aussenministerium
sucht eine Möglichkeit,
um den Gaddafi-Clan
unter Druck zu setzen.
Dann die Idee:
Die Schengen-Visaliste.
Wenn die Schweiz
den Libyern die Visa verweigert,
dürfen sie ganz Europa, den
Schengenraum, nicht mehr betreten.
Am 4. November 2009 ist es soweit.
Man hat die ganze Zeit
nach etwas gesucht,
woran sie ein Interesse haben.
Und das war der Punkt:
Sie wollten Visas.
Weil die Schweiz in Schengen war,
konnten wir durch eine Verweigerung
der Visa verhindern,
dass Libyer überhaupt
nach Europa reisen konnten.
Das hat ihnen weh getan.
Jetzt kommt Bewegung
in die Sache.
5 Tage
nach der Visa-Verweigerung
werden die gefangenen Schweizer
plötzlich in ein Taxi gesetzt,
das sie
zur Botschaft zurückfährt.
Wir waren ausser uns vor Freude.
Wir hatten nichts davon gewusst.
Plötzlich klopften wir
an der Tür der Botschaft.
Der Chauffeur rief: Rachid! Max!
Er hat vor Freude geweint.
Auch Lazzorotto war dort.
Alle weinten.
Es war der einzige Freudenausbruch
in der ganzen Geschichte.
Es war einer der bewegendsten
Momente meines Lebens,
sie wohlbehalten wiederzusehen.
Wunderbar.
Ab da leben die beiden Schweizer
eingeschlossen in der Botschaft.
Langeweile
wechselt sich ab mit Angst.
Das Lachen auf den Weihnachtsbildern
2009 täuscht.
Gaddafi hat inzwischen
den Spiess wieder umgedreht:
Er will die beiden
vor Gericht bringen.
Er verlangt,
dass sie die Botschaft verlassen.
Doch sie weigern sich.
Weil Gaddafis Clan
nicht mehr nach Europa reisen darf,
hat der Diktator inzwischen
allen Europäern die Einreise
nach Libyen untersagt.
Das kommt schlecht an
in der EU.
Micheline Calmy-Rey
wird in Brüssel heftig kritisiert -
auch weil sie das Visaverbot
ohne Vorwarnung eingeführt hatte.
Sie sagten zu mir: "Sie hätten
uns wenigstens warnen können."
"So geht das nicht."
Ich antwortete:
"Hätte ich es angekündigt,
hättet ihr mich unter
Druck gesetzt, es nicht zu tun."
"Wenn ihr die Situation retten
wollt, setzt Libyen unter Druck,
damit sie unsere
Geiseln ausreisen lassen."
Das Schicksal
der beiden Geiseln zählt wenig
angesichts der Interessen
gewisser Länder in Libyen.
Hätte sich die EU
gegenüber der Schweiz
nicht solidarischer zeigen sollen?
Ahh, jetzt ist
die Schweiz also EU-Mitglied.
Fantastisch. Eine gute Nachricht!
Wir haben keine Probleme mit Libyen.
Die Schweiz schon.
Wir lieben die Schweiz,
aber sie darf nicht Europa
in Geiselhaft nehmen.
Die Europäer haben uns nicht
geholfen, weil sie uns lieben,
sondern weil wir miteinander
eine Allianz bilden,
weil wir das Schengen-Abkommen
unterzeichnet haben.
Der Entscheid der Schweiz
brachte die EU in Schwierigkeiten
gegenüber Libyen,
das Vergeltungsmassnahmen
beschlossen hatte.
Das ermöglichte uns,
die Verhandlungen zu beschleunigen,
um das Problem zu lösen.
Hinterher
muss man Micheline Calmy-Rey
zu diesem mutigen Entscheid
gratulieren,
auch wenn er zu einigen schwierigen
Momenten zwischen uns geführt hatte.
Neue Verhandlungen beginnen,
jetzt unter europäischer Leitung.
Micheline Calmy-Rey
muss das Visaverbot zurückziehen.
Die libysche Seite ihrerseits zieht
ihr Visaverbot für EU-Bürger zurück.
Aber die sofortige Freilassung
der Geiseln verweigert sie.
Ich habe sie zum Weinen gebracht.
Aber sie weinte nicht wegen mir.
Sie war am Ende ihrer Kräfte.
Der Druck war massiv.
Und sie war
nicht bereit, nachzugeben.
Ausser, die beiden Geiseln
würden gleichzeitig freigelassen.
Aber Libyen willigte nicht ein.
Gaddafi stellt ein Ultimatum.
Bern habe wenige Stunden,
um die Geiseln auszuliefern.
Er hat
Unterschiedliches vor mit den beiden:
Rachid soll frei kommen.
Aber Max muss ins Gefängnis.
Am 21. Februar 2010
umstellt die libysche Armee
die Schweizer Botschaft.
Stefano Lazzorotto versucht,
Zeit zu gewinnen.
Je mehr Zeit verging,
desto stärker wurde der Druck.
Schliesslich drohten sie mir,
wegen meiner mangelnden Bereitschaft
würden sie in die Botschaft
eindringen und Max Göldi mitnehmen.
In diesem Moment dachten wir,
es könne alles passieren.
Dass die Botschaft aufgebrochen wird
und sie ins Gebäude kämen
und unsere Leute sowie
die Geiseln gefährdet sind.
Auch das alles zerstört wird.
Allenfalls könnten auch vertrauliche
Dokumente gestohlen werden.
Für uns wäre das ein GAU gewesen.
In diesem Moment bittet
die österreichische Botschafterin
ihre Kollegen in Libyen um Hilfe.
Diese begeben sich
in die Schweizer Botschaft,
um eine gewaltsame Erstürmung
zu verhindern.
Das war
ein starkes Zeichen der Solidarität
in einem schwierigen Moment.
Denn wir wussten nicht,
wie es weitergehen sollte.
Bern hatte mir geraten,
keinen Widerstand zu leisten.
Bern sagt, die Botschaft
müsse sich für einen Angriff wappnen.
Der Diplomat befiehlt also, alle
offiziellen Dokumente zu verbrennen.
Mitten in der Nacht ruft Libyen
die rebellischen Botschafter zusammen
und wirft ihnen vor:
"Ihr beschützt
einen verurteilten Verbrecher!"
Die Botschafter wollen sich nicht
mit dem libyschen Regime anlegen
und fordern von den Geiseln,
sich zu ergeben.
Diese haben keine andere Wahl.
Es war klar, dass Libyen
die Botschaft stürmen würde,
um uns festzunehmen.
Wir fragten die Schweizer Behörden:
"Was sollen wir tun?"
"Müssen wir uns ergeben?"
Ihre Antwort:
"Das müsst ihr entscheiden."
Die Schweiz
hatte immer die gleiche Haltung.
Sie überliess uns die Entscheidung
und blieb stets neutral.
Max traf eine Entscheidung,
doch sie fiel ihm schwer.
Er sprach mit seiner Familie
und sah keinen anderen Ausweg.
Es war ein dramatischer Moment.
Ich habe keine Worte dafür.
Er bewies bemerkenswerten Mut.
Eine surreale Szene.
Stefano Lazzorotto verfolgt
in seinem blauen Auto die Polizei.
Er will Max Göldi
nicht aus den Augen verlieren.
Rachid hingegen ist fast frei.
Als letzte Erniedrigung
muss er ein Interview geben,
das ihm zuvor diktiert worden ist.
Rachid Hamdani sagt,
die Schweizer Regierung habe ihn in
eine schwierige Situation gebracht,
indem sie ihn gegen seinen Willen in
ihrer Botschaft festgehalten habe.
In einem Interview dankt er
den Libyern für ihre Fürsorge,
die sie ihm während seines langen
Aufenthalts zukommen liessen.
Dann ist der Weg frei
für die Rückreise in die Schweiz.
Max hingegen ist wieder im Gefängnis.
Hannibal will seine
grosse Menschlichkeit demonstrieren
und besucht ihn,
begleitet von Medienvertretern.
Heute hat Ihre Mutter Geburtstag.
Ja. Ihr Besuch ehrt mich sehr.
Ich habe meine Familie
schon lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Es tut mir sehr leid, was ihnen und
ihrer Familie in Genf passiert ist.
Hannibal erlaubt Max Göldi,
seine Mutter anzurufen.
Max Göldi weinte, als er seiner
Mutter zum Geburtstag gratulierte.
Hannibal sah, wie ihm die
Tränen hinunterliefen und sagte:
"Wie einfach ist es doch,
jemanden einzusperren."
Hannibal hat seine Rache. Aber die
Geschichte ist noch nicht zu Ende.
Für mich war es sehr schwierig
und auch demütigend,
die schwarze Liste
vor den Libyern aufzuheben.
Das war ein grosses Risiko.
Meine Kollegen aus dem Bundesrat
sagten zu Recht,
dass wir so keine Garantie hätten,
die beiden Geiseln frei zu bekommen.
Micheline Calmy-Rey
versucht einen letzten Ausweg:
Sie kontaktiert Cecilia Attias,
die Ex-Frau des französischen
Premierministers Sarkozy.
Als sie noch
französische Präsidentengattin war,
hatte sie dazu beigetragen,
dass Gaddafi die bulgarischen
Krankenschwestern freiliess.
Micheline Calmy Rey
hat alles versucht.
Es ist nicht einfach, Bürger seines
Landes in Geiselhaft zu wissen.
Sie war sehr besorgt
und liess nichts unversucht.
Da sagte ich zu ihr:
"Ich schaue, was ich tun kann."
Cecilia Attias reist nach Tripolis
und trifft sich
mit dem Premierminister.
Ein Treffen mit Diktator Gaddafi
persönlich kommt nicht zustande,
aber sie telefoniert lange mit ihm.
Ihm ging es nur um die Macht.
Etwas anderes gab es nicht für ihn.
Er musste immer
seine Macht beweisen.
Doch dann sah ich eine Möglichkeit.
Er trug auf dem Revers
seines Jackets eine Afrikakarte,
er wollte ein Tor für Afrika sein.
Ich sagte zu ihm:
Niemand nimmt Sie Ernst, wenn Sie
Geiseln in ihrer Gewalt haben.
Wenn Sie also wirklich
ein Tor für Afrika sein wollen,
verhalten Sie sich ehrenhaft!
Libyen macht ihr darauf
einen Vorschlag.
Wenn sie durchsetzen könne, dass die
Genfer Polizisten bestraft würden,
könne sie Libyen
mit den Geiseln verlassen.
Cecilia Attias
kontaktiert Micheline Calmy Rey,
die ihrerseits den
Genfer Stadtratspräsidenten anruft.
Sie rief mich an und sagte,
sie habe eine Gesandte in Tripolis.
Wenn ich ihr versichern könne, dass
die Polizeibeamten bestraft würden,
kämen die Geiseln frei.
Ich sagte, es stehe ausser
Frage, die Beamten zu bestrafen.
Sie sei ja einmal im gleichen Kanton
in der Regierung gewesen
und wisse deshalb,
dass das nicht gehe.
Sie erwiderte, wir sollten
einfach Funktionäre nehmen,
die bald pensioniert würden
und so tun, als würden sie bestraft.
Ich versprach ihr, ich würde das
in der Regierung besprechen,
aber ich sei ziemlich sicher,
dass die Antwort negativ sei.
Man kann ja nicht einfach
Unschuldigen oder Polizeibeamten,
die nur ihre Pflicht getan hatten,
den Schwarzen Peter zuschieben.
Wir mussten
den Rechtstaat respektieren.
Das war eine ständige Forderung
der Libyer.
Jedes Mal haben
wir in Genf angefragt,
und jedes Mal
haben sie abgelehnt.
Und dann hat auch die
Eidgenossenschaft Nein gesagt.
Auge um Auge, Zahn um Zahn.
Wir mussten sie beim Wort nehmen.
Während den Verhandlungen haben
die Libyer immer wieder gefordert,
dass diese Polizeibeamten
bestraft würden.
Mehr noch, dass sie entlassen
oder frühzeitig pensioniert würden,
so in der Art.
Die Genfer Polizeibeamten,
die Hannibal festgenommen haben,
fühlten sich seit
jenem verhängnisvollen Tag bedroht.
Sie befürchten,
sie könnten von Gaddafis Leuten
auf Genfer Boden entführt werden.
2 Jahre lang gehen sie jeden Abend
auf einem anderen Weg nach Hause.
Die libyschen Sicherheitsleute
hatten den Ruf,
effizient und brutal
zu sein.
Die Genfer Polizei
war deshalb sehr besorgt.
Was, wenn der Gaddafi-Clan
selber Justiz üben
und sich
an den Polizeibeamten rächen würde?
Diese Möglichkeit
mussten wir ernst nehmen.
Im August 2009
hätte Hans-Rudolf Merz in Libyen
beinahe die Namen
der 3 Polizeibeamten,
die Hannibal verhaftet hatten,
bekannt gegeben.
Im letzten Moment wurde
die Vereinbarung jedoch geändert.
Wir konnten verhindern,
dass in der vom Bundesratspräsi-
denten unterzeichneten Vereinbarung
die Namen der Polizeibeamten
aufgeführt waren.
Aber wir mussten
einem Schiedsgericht zustimmen.
10. Mai 2010.
Die Vereinbarung ist unterzeichnet.
Sie enthält im Wesentlichen
die Bedingungen,
die Merz ausgehandelt hatte.
Zudem soll die Schweiz 1,5 Mio. Fr.
an ein karitatives Werk überweisen,
das vom Gaddafi-Clan
ausgesucht worden ist.
Doch noch muss Max Göldi frei kommen.
Micheline Calmy-Rey
und der spanische Aussenminister
begeben sich nach Tripolis.
Eine riskante Reise.
Dort erleben sie
2 turbulente Tage.
Zuerst müssen sie
eine Erklärung abgeben,
dass die Einhaltung der Vereinbarung
garantiert sei.
Dann folgt eine Pressekonferenz.
Gaddafi lässt die Delegation
mehr als 24 Std. warten.
Endlich werden alle
ins Zelt des Diktators gerufen.
Es war irgendwie surreal.
Wir waren mitten in Tripolis
in einer Kaserne,
die mit Stacheldraht
eingezäunt war.
Dort gab es eine riesige Wiese,
und darauf stand ein Zelt.
Wir waren
etwa 60 bis 80 Personen.
Man sagte uns, das sei
die Versammlung der Vergebung.
Ich hielt mich zurück.
Ich sagte zu mir: "Jetzt können wir
endlich Max Göldi mitnehmen,
also bleibe ruhig!"
Monsieur Gaddafi fragte mich:
"Woher kommen Sie?" Ich sagte:
"Aus Genf." Er sagte: "Ach so."
Dann begann er die Schweiz
zu beschimpfen und sagte,
die Westschweiz
sollte zu Frankreich gehören.
Ich antwortete: Keinesfalls!
Und erklärte ihm die
historischen Zusammenhänge.
Da erhob sich
Monsieur Berlusconi und sagte:
"Hören Sie, ich lasse nicht zu,
dass die Schweiz kritisiert wird."
"Ich wurde im Krieg von der Schweiz
aufgenommen."
"Das ist ein friedliches Land."
Da sagte Gaddafi nichts mehr
gegen die Schweiz.
Die Bundesrätin
und der spanische Minister
gehen voller Hoffnung
in ihr Hotel zurück.
Dort müssen sie erneut warten.
Am Nachmittag erhielten wir
vom Premierminister
die schlechte Nachricht, dass Herr
Göldi nicht mit uns ausreisen könne.
Da riskierte ich alles und drohte:
"Die Komödie ist zu Ende."
"Wir kommen nie mehr nach Libyen
und das wird
gewaltige Konsequenzen haben."
Es war eine der härtesten Verhand-
lungen, die ich je erlebt hatte.
Die Drohung des spanischen
Aussenministers zeigt Wirkung.
Micheline Calmy Rey
kann sich endlich entspannen.
Der libysche Premierminister
persönlich lässt Max Göldi frei.
Doch dieser darf nicht
mit den Ministern zurückreisen.
Er muss allein zurückfliegen.
Ich schickte ihm eine SMS um sicher
zu sein, dass er im Flugzeug sass.
Er antwortete sofort:
"Ich warte auf den Abflug."
"Anscheinend
hat das Flugzeug Verspätung."
Wir warteten ein paar Minuten.
Seine SMS lautete: "Flugzeug rollt."
Max Göldi steigt in Tunis
in den Bundesratsflieger um.
Am 13. Juni 2010, nach 22 Monaten,
ist er endlich wieder
in seiner Heimat.
Ich bin müde, aber sehr glücklich,
dass ich endlich wieder
in der Schweiz bin.
Ich bin Opfer eines Konfliktes
geworden,
der nichts mit mir zu tun hat.
Dies ist ein sehr
emotionaler Moment für mich.
Und ich bitte Sie um Verständnis.